china ist auf dem besten weg rohstoffe
auf dem mond abzubauen und könnte damit
weltweit einen vorsprung erreichen der
für andere nationen dann nur noch schwer
einzuholen wäre
und im moment läuft alles nach plan und
das ist nur ein gebiet auf dem china den
westen wohl bald überholen wird und es
ist eines der wichtigsten wie ist die
lage jetzt den klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
in china läuft dem westen im moment in
vielen dem run up und nicht wenige in
der politik lassen die alarmglocken
klingeln gerade erst wurde der deutsche
roboterhersteller kuka von einer
chinesischen firma gekauft und wenn man
sich in der app von 1 bot umschaut die
segway gekauft haben und jetzt die
führenden hersteller in diesem bereich
sind sieht man auch nur noch chinesisch
im wahrsten sinne des wortes alle
kommentare sind in chinesisch oder fast
hatte ich habe mir schon überlegt ob man
nicht schon bald chinesisch lernen
sollte so oder so china übernimmt
weltweit eine immer größere rolle
und man sollte dabei nicht vergessen
dass es ein totalitärer staat ist sie
sind zum beispiel führend in den
bereichen elektro autos regenerative
energien und vielleicht auch schon bald
in der kernfusion denn darüber wird im
moment ausgerechnet in der chinesischen
raumfahrt nachgedacht die chinesen waren
2016 als erste in der lage ein
wasserstoff plasma mit einer temperatur
von 50 millionen grad für mehr als eine
minute nämlich genau für 102 sekunden
aufrechtzuerhalten ein kleiner aber
bedeutender schritt auf dem weg zur
kernfusion in ihrem experiment etwa
superconducting tokamak kurz ist reaktor
wollen sie in diesen rekord schon bald
um das zehnfache überbieten
china ist übrigens auch anita den
fusionsreaktor beteiligt der im moment
in südfrankreich in katar rasch gebaute
der ideale brennstoff für die kernfusion
wäre aber helium 3
und davon gibt es auf der erde nur 15
tonnen also insgesamt auf dem mond
während es mindestens eine millionen
genau deshalb ist china jetzt aktiv
geworden was nur wenige wissen bereits
vor fünf jahren haben
chinesen einen rover auf dem mond
abgesetzt und bis 2020 sollen zwei
weitere missionen folgen ihr ziel den
abbau von helium 3 auf dem mond
vorzubereiten
die zweite sonde soll dann beim proben
wieder zur erde zurückbringen noch ist
das alles hypothetisch und der abbau
dieser riesigen mengen helium-3 ist
nicht gerade leicht da es im gesamten
mondstaub gleichmäßig verteilt ist wem
es aber gelingt eine technik für den
abbau zu entwickeln
der hätte ende dieses jahrhunderts
vielleicht die kontrolle über den
wichtigsten rohstoff für die menschheit
ja wenn es neues dazu gibt dann halte
ich euch natürlich hier auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video dazu und
zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir genau hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht mehr einen auf
die glocke zu geben denn nur dann werdet
ihr immer informiert wenn es ein neues
video gibt ja hier also hier geht es
weiter mit menschen wollen auf dem mond
siedeln das plant nämlich die
europäische weltraumagentur esa schaut
es euch an
wenn ihr wissen wollt und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt kann